thank you very much for being with us
and shops were opening from tomorrow how
important is it that we get the economy
moving again so good morning Sophie
great development you again as so yeah
the answer is that it's extremely
important the fact is that about 2/3 of
our economy is made up by consumer
spending and of course retail is the
biggest part of that so this will be a
really critical part of the effort to
get the economy started again all
emphasis though has to be done on doing
it safely and that's what all retailers
will be making sure they're ready to do
when they open tomorrow the thing is it
will only be a success of people
actually go out and start spending money
begun visit the shops and for many
people there is a great deal of fear
about whether or not it's safe to do so
it's gonna rely on consumer spending
isn't it
this is the critical point about safety
so if I was still managing director
Jonas today I've been making sure that
tomorrow we would open safely and I'm
sure forces of all retail companies are
doing that because you're right
data this weekend says good proportion
of people are really reluctant to leave
their homes so tomorrow what we have to
do is demonstrate that it is safe to
return to the high street other parts of
this as well demonstrate it's safe to
use public transport if that's the only
way you have of traveling of course
because that way we will steadily coax
people back to what I hate user word
might be described as a more normal life
it is important because of the share of
our economy the consumer spending makes
up so this steadily building confidence
is the critical mission I mean the to me
to disassociate distancing rule is one
thing that many businesses say that they
are struggling with in particular the
hospitality sector according to UK
hospital 'ti reducing it to one meter is
the difference for many businesses
between remaining closed and reopening
and that at two meters a third of
hospitality businesses can't reopen and
a million jobs will be lost do you want
to see that rule changed so it's not
just hospitality it would be same in
education same in all part of public
transport everywhere is to say just an
example I had yesterday about
universities thinking about their
reopening they can't use their visa so
everywhere this isn't relevant so of
course I want to see it change but
absolutely clear it can only change if
the scientific advice is that it is safe
so to do so actually I do welcome the
formal review that the Prime Minister
said he's putting in place to get us to
look at this properly and hopefully as
no one is going to resist it hopefully
we will be able to make that change if
that's the right advice you mentioned
schools there and the difficulties for
schools reopening how concerned are you
at the prospect of so many children not
returning to the classroom until
September not only for their own life
chances but also for the economy as well
very concerned I mean there's two
aspects of this that your question draws
out first of all parents and the
children to be in school so that they
can return to their their job sources
that's critical but most important thing
of all is we know very clearly that the
children who are missing out most of
those from disadvantaged community so it
really is important that we try to get
back now encouragingly because that's
but it baits be very polarized over this
either they are or they aren't
encouraging across the West Midlands
about 50% of primary schools are now
returning some hoping to bring further
EUR groups back so I hope that steady
common-sense approach will occur and
just finally and you've spoken a lot
about the future of the high street mean
we've talked about it times over the
last few years and the challenges the
high street faces it feels exacerbated
in the lockdown when the high street is
shot and yet many big online retailers
have been able to keep shipping out
goods to people's homes as we come out
of lockdown do you think the government
needs to look again at what they can do
to support high streets who were up
against big online competitors at
one-word answer yes to be fair some good
things have already happened so of
course there was the business rate and
discount or removal actually or this
financial year as a clear measure to
help the physical high street but I hope
two other things will continue to be
thought about first of all a permanent
reform of business rates we've talked
about how they fall disproportionately
on the high street and of course on big
manufacturer I hope as well we will be
thinking further about the digital sales
tax making sure that online companies do
pay a fair share of tax so there's a
level playing field and I also will be
thinking about how we can more quickly
remodel our high streets so they can be
in a successful place of the future but
to finish on an optimistic note note I
do believe that one of the things that
come out of this is this real sort of
concentration on local areas so I'm
optimistic that customers will actually
be very supportive of their local high
streets because obviously they're this
or the sense of community so let's hope
that we see that in the coming weeks I
thank you very much
always good to torture and I Street that
thanks